[Applause]
let me introduce our two presenters for
this award both members of the Nikhil
committee marcus who is co-president of
strand releasing which is celebrating
their 30th anniversary this year with
retrospectives across the country he
resides in both los angeles and san
francisco and he served six years on the
nickel fellowships committee and Kirsten
kiwi Smith is a screenwriter and
producer she co-wrote the hit comedies
Legally Blonde 10 Things I Hate About
You she's the man and the House Bunny
among others this is her sixth year on
the nickel committee presenting the
award to Aaron Chung our Marcus who and
Kiwi Smith
[Laughter]
thank you thank you guys
oh that was beautiful I was so beautiful
we love this cry no we when we read this
script we sat together and like teenage
girls yeah and we were like pairing
notes we said oh my god we just
absolutely love this one yeah we flipped
out we flipped out like we fell
headfirst into this world and heart
first and these characters are so
beautiful and you know the relationship
is complex and the writing is so poetic
Aaron it's just gorgeous you know Aaron
just brilliantly captures the
naturalness and authenticity of teenage
female voices and what's crazy is he
graduated from film school two years ago
and and he has written five screenplays
this is his fifth screenplay
he's written across so many genres he's
written action horror sci-fi he's
written a high school comedy which I
personally cannot wait to read and he's
culminated his work culminated in this
screenplay and we got to meet him for
yesterday which feels like a lifetime
ago I want him at the luncheon and he
reminded me that we'd actually met
before because he was an intern a year
ago from my manager so we've already we
were longtime friends cut to now a year
later and he entered his very first
screenwriting competition the nickel
anyone which is so impressive
and and yesterday we got to hand him his
we got to hold his hand him an Oscar to
hold and we just fit for the like the
first time and we just have a feeling
this is not gonna be his last time that
wasn't his last time that was only his
first time holding an Oscar and we Aaron
just congratulations we we thank you for
bringing all your your poetry and
artistry to this stage and and to the
community we just can't wait to get to
work with you and and get to know you in
congratulations
and make thank you for making such a
great script about two girls who fall in
love yes such a beautiful way yes
[Laughter]
come on up Aaron
oh my god there's so many of you um well
first of all Thank You Kiwi and Marcus
for that very very flattering
introduction thank you to West Rosa
Mandela and Geeta for rescuing my words
Wow thank you to the Academy
Jennifer Joan the entire committee for
this opportunity and for seeing
something in me that I haven't seen yet
um and thank you to my Florida State
family my close friends my colleagues my
mentors and teachers who have helped me
and guided me to develop my voice and to
make this script and most of all thank
you to my family my tireless mother my
resilient father and my supportive
sister and my amazing brother-in-law
thank you so so much for just everything
so before today as I was preparing the
speech I was writing about Who I am and
why I chose to become a writer and why I
chose to write this script and it
recently just felt off to me because
that's not the reason why I want to
write I mean I want to share my voice
but it's not just my voice it's
everyone's voice and I want to connect
everyone's problems and struggles and
conflicts and show that we have a lot
more in common than we believe and I
wrote fable on Aisling two characters
these two kids who had every right to
not be together because they were so
different and I and they just happened
to find each other and fall in love and
through that they've brought a little
bit of Hope in their crumbling world and
I know that sounds a little cheesy and
belongs in a Hallmark card but I believe
it brings a little true because not just
storytellers but like all
of us people we have this amazing
superpower to empathize and connect and
understand each other in ways that no
other living creatures can but we often
don't use that power and instead we
weaponize our experiences and our
opinions and our intellect and our
accomplishments to make others feel
inferior and silence them which is just
a shame because we all we are all
sharing this common goal this one dream
which is to try and be better versions
of ourselves than we were yesterday so I
stand before you today to make a promise
that tomorrow or the day after that and
the day after that I will try and try to
be a better person than you see here
today I will try to empathize I will try
to listen I'll try to speak up for
others and give a voice to the voiceless
and extend a helping hand to those who
are in dire need of it and I promise
that I will try to be just a better role
model and I feel like a lot of us we all
should have that goal and although we
will all stumble and fall and make
mistakes trust me I have made billions
of them and I regret and feel so ashamed
for so many of them but no matter what
it's it's what we should do because it
could bring a little bit of hope and
love into our own crumbling world so
thank you so much you are all wonderful
lovely beautiful people thank you